Welcome to Ear Biscuits, I'm Rhett.
And I'm Link, this week
at the table of round.
Wow, you would've thought
it would've been ingrained by now.
This week at the round
table of dim lighting,
that's it, not the
table of round lighting.
Well it is round, I mean,
we have a globular light, it is round.
And it's not as dim as it used to be.
Yeah, I saw that there was a post,
Kiko, there was a post, that
somebody was taking pictures
and doing different strata of screens
of how Ear Biscuits has
gotten increasingly less dim.
Well it got really dim for a little bit,
and that was because something was wrong.
Well no, it started off dim
because there was no video,
and we had guests and
we had this idea that,
if you create a dark space,
people are gonna share
their dark secrets, and
I believe that it helped.
It's welcoming, yeah.
I mean, we were down in our basement,
and it was just us and somebody,
getting into it in the dark.
It wasn't a basement, though.
No, it wasn't.
It felt like a basement,
at the other studio.
You're right, it felt like a basement,
'cause there were no, all
the windows were blacked out.
You're right, it wasn't a basement.
And then when we started doing video,
which comes out a week later,
YouTube channel Ear Biscuits,
if you're listening and
you wanna start watching,
and then we were like,
"Man, it's a little too dim.
"We gotta make it brighter
because it's a video."
I mean, you kinda wanna see the people.
But it was still dimmer
than it needed to be.
Because it was like, "Man, it's..."
We've increasingly made it less dim.
But I saw that post too, and I thought
that it had a temporary really dark,
it was a dark time.
We had a dark time.
And that was just because something
had been dialed in wrong,
but then we fixed that,
and then we've slowly
gotten it a little bit brighter.
Did you add this, there's a
pull-down projector screen
just beyond this main camera here,
was that added just as a reflector
or was that already there?
Mhm, it was added after,
yeah, we decided that we wanted
it a little bit brighter.
Okay.
Yeah, it reflects.
What'd you do, bring Ben
in here to have ideas?
Or you just came up with this?
It was kinda like a team effort
with me and Ben, yeah.
Yeah, it seemed like a Ben thing.
So, we got, it's a projector screen
but there's no projector anywhere,
we're just using a projector
screen as a bounce.
That is gratuitous.
We could project something.
We are high rolling, we
got a projector screen
with no projector, just for the bounce.
That's how high we're rolling.
That's how large we're living.
Let's put a projector right in between us.
Let's replace the Ear Biscuits
sign with a large projector.
Yeah, so while we're doing the podcast,
we can be watching a movie.
I wanna watch The Mandalorian again.
By the time this comes out, most all,
I don't know how many episodes there are,
so I know it's a little
late, but I just have to gush
a little bit, I'm still
trying to get you to watch it.
Oh, I'm gonna watch it,
but what about what we're
gonna talk about today?
Which is not The Mandalorian.
Oh yeah, this week
of the round table of dim lighting,
we're talking about our book.
We're gonna go into specific story points
based on your questions,
comments, desires.
"The Lost Causes of Bleak Creek"
has a lot of details and a lot of,
some controversy, it appears.
And this is going to be full of spoilers,
so, might I suggest, and
this'll be after the break
that we get into this, so if you end up,
if you haven't read the book yet,
before we get into these questions,
just stop this podcast and go pick it up.
Or listen to it on Audible.
You listen to this podcast
and you haven't read our book,
well you can listen to the
audio version of the book,
and it's kinda like a good
replacement for Ear Biscuits,
you know, for a little bit.
So go to Audible, go to
Amazon, get the Audible version
of the book and listen to that thing.
And then come back and
enjoy this discussion.
Now if you're the kind
of person who's like
"I'm not reading the book, I don't care
"how many times you guys say it,
"I'm not a reader."
We respect that, I guess.
That's cool, whatever.
I'd still push back a
little bit on that and say,
"Just read it, if you're
gonna read one book,
"read this book."
And then if you still are like
"I'm not a reader, and I'm
not gonna make my first book
"I ever read your book."
Then just keep listening.
Then just listen to this whole thing,
it's not gonna be that,
I mean we're gonna get
into a lot of things, but you know,
it's not gonna ruin it for you
if you ever do go back on
that and decide to read.
I mean it's, I'm gonna have
a moment of gratitude here,
I'm still so grateful that
this novel has been created
that we made it, and we wrote it,
that it's done, that it's bound,
and that it's sitting on shelves.
Oh, speaking of sitting on shelves,
me, Christy, and Lando,
we went to the mall, and,
well we were going to the Galleria.
But really, what we were
doing was we were going
to Din Tai Fung, 'cause
it was just us with Lando,
and we were like "We gotta
eat at a special place."
And maybe our favorite
restaurant as a family
is Din Tai Fung, they got these dumplings,
good gosh, you can look through a window
and they're folding these dumplings
at a rapid speed, something that would be
like one of those satisfying
manufacturing videos
that I would watch on Reddit.
It's just people working like robots,
they're just amazingly fast, and--
And they will be replaced by the robots.
Oh my gosh, and the dumplings are so good.
Dumpling robots.
I mean the wait was two hours,
but when I finally got in there,
what do you order from there,
'cause I order the crab
and pork dumplings.
I don't know, I just order
a little bit of everything.
Once you eat those, everything else is--
Crab and pork together?
Yeah, those are the best ones.
Soup dumplings, you bite
the edge and soup comes out,
and then you dip it in the vinegar
and the hot saucey stuff.
I don't think I would enjoy
eating those with you.
Do you make noises like that?
Yeah, I'll put the first one in my mouth.
Can only imagine you have a system.
They're not the best things for you,
especially when you eat as many as I eat,
so I try not to go there
but once a quarter,
but when I go, I go hard.
The first one I put in my mouth,
I was like "This thing is so good."
I close my eyes, man, I'm
sitting there in the restaurant,
and I've been transported to Shanghai.
That's Shanghai for you.
And I'm just like, savoring it.
That's one of my happy places.
You know when you're
going through a surgery,
having a syst removed, you're like--
I appreciate your passion
about dumplings, but--
You need to go to a happy
place, guess where I'm going,
crab and pork in my mouth!
You're really easily distracted today,
you've gotten off on two tangents.
Oh, the book.
Yeah, the book, that's
what we're talking about.
So we're waiting, so we go
over to Barnes and Noble,
and I'm like "Oh, I bet you
The Lost Causes of Bleak Creek
"is here," Christy's like "Yeah, I saw it,
"I've been in here a few days ago,
"and it's on this shelf
right there at the front,
"at the table, new fiction."
Yeah, the table that you wanna be on.
I felt, I looked at it but I didn't wanna
sit there and pick it up and stare at it,
like a lost child in the
mall that I just found.
Did you think about signing it?
Christy was like "You should sign it."
I was like "I don't wanna do that."
'Cause then you have to have this weird
interaction with Mr. Noble, or Mr. Barnes,
and be like "Excuse me sir,
"why are you writing in the book?"
"Well you know, I'm one of
the authors of this book.
"Depending on where it's printed online,
"you may not see me as the author,
"you might only see Rhett McLaughlin,
"because apparently
there's not enough space
"to put two authors on stuff,
"but I am on the front of the book,
"and when you put the discounted sticker,
"you also put that over my name."
So it's a novel for
number one New York Times
best-selling authors Rhett
McLaughlin and 20% off.
I just get the short
end of the stick, man.
Well your name's shorter.
With the second book, my
name needs to be first.
Okay.
Is that a deal?
You just said okay.
TBD.
We need to figure that out.
So I was a little self-conscious,
and then we kinda walked away,
I was like, I know what
the book looks like,
I'm not gonna buy it.
And you know there's escalators in there,
and I just noticed when
I went up the escalator
that I was turning back and looking down,
and looking at my book, I
just couldn't believe that,
we have a novel in Barnes and Noble.
Well I went to the Vroman's,
I guess is how you pronounce that.
Yeah, in Pasadena.
That's my go-to.
I like that as independent bookstore,
and they got a lot of cool stuff.
It's right next to the
Laemmle, which incidentally--
Subtitled movies?
No, I saw Jojo Rabbit there.
Oh, why didn't you invite me?
I just took Shepherd,
just me and Shepherd.
What's it rated?
It's PG-13.
Okay, he's 13.
He's 11, but I was with him,
I guided him through it.
Boy, speaking of tangents.
Is it good?
I gotta see it.
Taika Waititi was also in Mandalorian!
He's a freaking droid!
It's so good, but I'm
not talking about that,
I don't wanna get off on a tangent.
Isn't he great, though?
He's great in that, too.
He's even great as Hitler.
I mean it's just like, when
someone can make Hitler likable.
Spoiler alert.
I'm not gonna give away anything,
'cause he doesn't really
make Hitler likable.
If you understand what Hitler
represents in that movie,
okay, anyway, so...
I was longingly looking at the book
as I was going up to the
second and third floor,
but I didn't want Christy
to see me looking at it,
I thought she was like
"You looking down there
at your book, aren't you?"
I was like "Well yeah, it's my book,
"it's definitely, how often
"do you get to look in a bookstore
"and see your own book,
it's thrilling, man!"
Well I was in Vroman's, and I was like,
well of course I gotta find the book,
and I was actually
thinking I might sign it,
because last time I was in Vroman's,
one of the employees came
up to me and was like
"Rhett, would you mind signing some copies
"of the Book of Mythicality?"
Because they had that out in
the internet humor section,
or something like that.
With all the other YouTuber books.
But I was more excited about this,
'cause I was like, "Oh, our book's
"gonna be in the fiction section,
"in the part of the bookstore
that everybody goes,
"not the internet humor
that only if you're lost
"on your way to the
bathroom do you find it."
It'd be good for the toilet.
And so, it's not quite as well-organized
and set up as a Barnes and Noble,
in that there's also five
entrances to this bookstore,
and you don't know what's the front,
there's multiple cashiers.
I love that, because it
makes it easy to steal their books.
You know, they gotta
spread out their security,
I'm rolling out of there with books.
You know, Doom's a thick book.
But when you got multiple exits,
you just bide your time, and you're taking
that Doom down your pants.
That guy's got a lot of junk in his trunk,
shaped like a book.
I've not, and I do not
advocate stealing books.
But you can put it down your pants,
just pull it back out and purchase it.
So, I go to the fiction section,
and they have new and noteworthy,
that's what they call it, I think,
and there it was.
Well being as ours was new,
does that mean it wasn't noteworthy?
Oh, no, it's new and noteworthy.
Oh, it's both, not either or?
And but then they had
the bestsellers section,
which is a nice shelf with
a really nice light on it.
We weren't on that.
But that was before we were
technically a bestseller.
No, this was yesterday.
Oh, they didn't get the memo?
So, I almost, well a couple things,
I almost offered to sign one, or two,
there were only two left.
Oh, only two, you decided not to.
And then I was almost like,
"Put it on the bestseller,
it is a bestseller."
But, you know.
So you thought about
going into negotiations,
you're like "Excuse me,
I'd be more than happy
"to sign my novel, if
you'd be more than happy
"to put it under the lights."
Yeah, yeah, yeah, so we
can move these last two.
You could've just moved 'em over.
But that's a cool thing, a lot of people
have been reporting that
they've been going to
various bookstores and they're out,
they've sold out of a number of these.
There's more on the way, there's
a second printing already.
And the new printing's gonna say
"New York Times Bestseller."
Something like that, right,
that will be printed on it.
It's not gonna be a sticker,
but it will be over my name.
We're taking Link's name off,
and it's gonna say "A
novel from number one
"New York Times bestselling authors
"Rhett McLaughlin and this is also
"a New York Times bestselling book."
That's what it's gonna say.
Sorry, Link.
But you know what, you're in the back,
you're in the picture in the back
and you're standing in front of me, so,
I think that makes up for it.
I love the fact that you knew that
before you looked at it.
You know that I'm standing in
front of you in that picture.
Well, I knew that when
we chose this picture.
'Cause you didn't, you're
so much bigger than me.
No, I think you always stand
a little bit in front of me
because I'm taller, but this is like,
your elbow is all the way
across my belly button,
in my opinion that's just
a little too far in front.
My face is bigger than your face.
'Cause not only, I think
it's the wide angle lens
they're using to take this picture with,
so typically we'd be the same size,
but my head looks really really small,
and really far away.
So it all evens out,
is what I'm getting at.
I don't know if that evens out.
And another thing I thought,
is it's a really cool cover,
but people are putting
really bright colors
on covers now, kinda playing
the YouTube thumbnail game
with book covers.
Did we lose?
And I was like, I don't
know how much I would just,
it's a really cool cover,
but I don't know how eye-catching it is,
when you just put it
next to 20 other books.
Yeah, it doesn't have,
the letters should've been neon pink.
So, maybe the next printing,
we should call them
right now, go all neon.
We'll say "No explanation,
it's all neon this time."
Gotta get those clicks.
Okay, we're gonna answer some
questions about the book,
this is a good time for
you to pause the podcast
and go buy the book and read it.
BleakCreek.com.
But before we answer that question,
we're gonna tell you
where you can get this,
what do you call that, tie-dye?
Hoodie.
Call it a hoodie.
Look at this, this is like turtle tie-dye.
Look at that.
Now I got headphones on
underneath this hood,
that's why it looks so odd.
And you can look this odd, too.
Headphones not supplied.
Go to Mythical.com, this is
freshly hitting the store
upon the video release.
Or maybe it's not even until tomorrow.
One day, yeah.
So if you're watching this on day one,
you gotta be ready, 'cause
you know this thing's
gonna sell out because
it's warm, it's hoodie-ish.
And the people like the tie-dye,
they can't get enough of tie-dye things,
so it sells out quick, so go over there
and be part of the
reason it's selling out.
Check it, check out the back.
Every one's unique, it's like a snowflake.
'Cause it's really tie-dye.
And we're also selling snowflakes,
'cause it's that time of year.
Mythical.com, all types of
stuff, including gift cards.
I recommend asking for gift cards
from Mythical.com for the holidays,
that's a good thing to ask
for people to give you.
Or for you to give other people
if you're not selfish.
My grandma used to get
me McDonalds gift cards.
Christy, I've told you this,
Christy's parents gave us so
many McDonald's gift cards
once we moved out here
that we had a stack of 25.
Well they knew there
are a lot of McDonald's
out here in California, gotta eat.
Yeah, we don't tend to use them.
Well, okay.
Then sell 'em.
Sell 'em on the street.
We buy a lot of McDonald's
for the show, I should just bring 'em in.
Mythical.com, rep your
boys, be your mythical best.
So we have questions from loyal listeners
and avid readers, and a lot of discussions
happening on the Mythical Society Discord,
as well, so I think that's gonna,
we've read all of that,
so I think that's going to
color some of our answers,
and I think that, I know we should wait
for the Ruby questions until the end.
So, let's save those but start
anywhere you wanna start.
Let's start with a question
from Mythical Cop Wife.
We've met her a number of times,
that's why we're in her profile picture.
Very engaged member of the
Mythical Community, Society,
et cetera, "I would love to know more
"on Whitewood's backstory on transforming
"from a seemingly normal
person to the headmaster
"slash cult leader he became.
"What made him decide to go the route
"of forming a reform school?
"Was there no other way
to get his Ruby back?"
This is a, I think that this question
represents, or is related to,
a conversation that I have seen
quite a lot of people having.
I feel like the fact that our antagonist
is revealed to have some humanity
and almost might elicit
some of your sympathy
is something that people
have kinda struggled with,
they struggle with wrapping
their minds around,
"What am I supposed to
think about this guy?
"Are you guys trying
to justify his actions
"by explaining that the motivation is him
"doing whatever he can for his daughter?"
And some people are like
"Obviously, I don't care
what your motivation was,
"your actions have hurt so
many more people, that,"
I'll just say, first thing,
our intention in doing that was
unlike, what was the bad
dude in Captain Planet?
I never watched Captain Planet.
The guy who polluted, and it seemed like,
the reason that the guy who
polluted who was the evil dude
in Captain Planet, it seems
like he just got a kick
out of just polluting the Earth.
I'm getting a message.
Your hair is messed up.
I'm getting a message, look at that,
you talking about that?
It's bothering you, thank you.
Jen is bothered 'cause
my hair was messed up
after the hoodie.
Yeah, I was gonna let it ride.
You weren't gonna say anything?
Actually, I couldn't tell from my angle.
How's this?
But he polluted, and
as a kid watching that,
I was just like "This guy's just evil
"for the sake of being evil,"
I didn't even make any connection to,
and I don't know if the show
did make a connection to,
oh no, this guy's committed to industry,
and therefore its pollution
is just a byproduct.
It seems like he just was a bad dude
who wanted to pollute the planet.
But I think in reality,
everyone who does something
that is wrong, for the most part,
has their own internal
morality that is telling them
that what they're doing
is justified, right?
Most people make the decisions
and then rationalize them,
and we just kinda wanted something that,
you take this person and
you've got all this hate
built up for them, and then you see that
"Oh, actually, he has reasons."
That doesn't excuse his actions,
but the world's a messy place.
And people are complicated.
It's not justification,
but it's explanation.
I mean it's like, didn't you wanna know?
Why's this guy doing this?
He's constructed, I mean and
I guess that's the question,
why make a school, why have
a reform school, and...
Well that's because that's what he knows,
he was a principal in his former life,
so he has run a school before.
And there was an opportunity,
because with the way that
Bleak Creek worked, there was a need
for someone to step in and say
"I can solve one of
your biggest problems."
Which is, "I can address
one of your biggest fears,"
which is "What's gonna
happen to our children?
"Are they gonna stay on
the straight and narrow
"or are they gonna go wayward?"
You know, as a parent,
there are just times
when you're struck with
"Oh my gosh, how are my
children gonna turn out?"
And "Am I doing enough?"
Am I doing enough to help them become
contributing members of society,
people who follow their heart,
that are kind, you want,
but if you oversimplify that,
or at times, as a parent,
you just get to, I just
want 'em to act right.
If I could just do that,
then maybe everything else
would fall into place, because
if they start acting wrong,
then that's a red flag that something's
really going wrong, deeper,
that I'm really screwing up as a parent.
And so, I think he was smart enough
to see that that fear goes
very deep in a parent,
so if I can tap into that
and present the solution
for a kid that they're just
throwing their hands up,
"I don't know what to do with this kid.
"She's pulling the
pants off of mannequins.
"She's embarrassing me, she's,
"they're interrupting
prayers at the pig picking."
Then that's, it's a nice, simple solution.
"And hey, the kids don't even
have to live with my anymore."
Well I think there's three
contributing factors, right,
that kinda, the first thing
was, the keeper specifically
asked for kids who've kinda
gone their own way, right,
kids who weren't falling in line.
So you gotta find those kids, right?
Right, that's his problem.
So, okay, and then the second thing is,
is that he's got experience
with school administration,
and then the third thing is,
is kinda what you're getting at,
which is, early 90s North Carolina,
really America in general,
were still in the midst of moral panic
that really started, that really kinda
hit its peak in the 80s,
when parents started really
worrying about Satanism,
I mean we remember very very clearly,
there was a whole lot of moral panic
around people actually worshiping Satan.
We actually were told that "No, you guys,
"people are worshiping Satan."
Never mind the fact that
the whole Church of Satan
was started as almost a mockery
of the idea of religion in general.
I remember thinking as a kid, I was like,
"So you're telling me
that there are people
"who worship Satan, which means
"that they believe in the framework
"that there's a God and there's a Satan,
"and they're choosing the bad guy."
This is illogical on so
many different levels.
'Cause you're buying into the worldview
that includes Satan and then choosing him.
That's just, I'm not saying
that no one does that,
but it's not a societal
problem, and it never was.
We knew enough bad kids to be like
"Oh, that's a bad kid,
"I bet he would like to worship Satan."
He's not saying that he does, but.
And then we were told that if you played
all this rock music
backwards, backmasting,
we would literally go--
Backmasking.
Masking, yeah, we would literally go
to these presentations where
these guys would get up
and they would play
Led Zeppelin and AC/DC,
and other bands backwards,
and show all the Satanic messages.
Whose power is Satan?
That's what Robert Plant
sang in reverse on a song.
And I remember that being
a film from the 70s,
it seemed like a 70s-ish film
that was then screened again
in the early early 90s for us,
at Campbell University.
Was a little bit behind.
Well it was, they were still trying
to eradicate the, Led
Zeppelin was still popular.
But I think this is,
what I'm pointing at is,
in line with what you were
saying before, which is,
what an effective way
to manipulate people,
and manipulate their
behavior, is to understand
what their greatest fears are,
and then you can basically
just begin selling them any
kind of bullshit you want to.
Especially within the, if it works
within the framework of
what they already believe.
Exactly, so I'm saying, if you tell people
that rock music is actually
a subversive way to worship Satan,
and that's consistent with the fears
that they already have about it,
then you can get them
to believe things like,
people are intentionally
putting Satanic messages
into their song, because they
legitimately worship Satan.
If anyone actually ever did that,
it was because they were playing into it
in a tongue in cheek way,
but anyway, so Whitewood is in a community
where this is the way people think,
and he's like "This is
what my experience is,
"and these are the kids that I need
"in order to accomplish my mission."
So you do that mathematical equation
and you kinda come up with a
really strict reform school
that the kids have to live at,
so you gotta have control.
And then of course you've
eventually gotta get
some other adults to help you out,
and you've gotta manipulate them as well.
And the way you do that is twofold.
One, you play a mean organ at the church.
I mean, it's hard to argue with that.
He's there every Sunday,
playing that organ, you know?
That means a lot.
He might have made a
run at being a pastor,
but that takes a lot more time.
And then the second thing is,
you master that pit barbecue,
and you win 'em over.
You win 'em over.
People can overlook a world of hurt,
literally, they overlooked deaths,
which is something that we wrestled with,
'cause it's like "Man,
once you have kids dying,
"is this town really gonna let
this school just continue?"
Well, but that happens all the time.
I mean, in my mind, it's
not that big of a leap.
People let injustice fester,
especially when the person
who's in charge of it seems legitimate,
and there seems to be a
legitimate explanation,
and it's like "Oh, okay,
three kids over a decade
"have died in accidents at this place."
And this is largely based
on, so the reform school
in the book, we had the
whole thing sketched out,
but then we actually, once we
had outlined the entire book,
we found out about this reform school.
Yeah, Lance found this article
and sent it to us.
Somewhere in the northeast,
that even up until,
within the last decade,
had operated, and they had
found that they were doing
all kinds of crazy disciplinary
things on the kids,
including rolling them up in a carpet.
Yep, because we had written,
let's see, we, I'm trying to figure out
if we knew or if we changed
it, but there was a box.
We had not decided what the specific
disciplinary thing was, but we knew
we wanted it to be something
where kids were isolated,
and we wanted it to seem
kinda like the carpet thing,
so yeah, the first draft, it was the box,
and it was a wooden box that
was about two and a half feet
on each side, and you basically
sort of ball a kid up,
and you'd put them in this dark box
that had some breathing holes,
and then the guy would come
in and kinda kick it around,
and you would end up upside down
and you couldn't get turned,
or it's too small to turn around inside.
But I just thought that,
there's just nothing, it
just wasn't as memorable
or as visceral as the roll.
So the carpet roll is a
real thing they did to kids,
and these kids at a certain,
once they reached adulthood,
if I remember correctly,
a lot of them were
troubled, it had residual effects,
and there was a lot of suicide.
A lot of them were dying,
and then there was an investigation,
through Facebook, "Whatever
happened to my classmates,"
and then it turns out a lot
of 'em had committed suicide.
Yeah, I don't remember that detail,
but there was a lot of bad
stuff going on at the time,
and people didn't, they raised an eyebrow,
but it didn't cause any action.
So it's sad that these things do happen.
A related question, Shell, thevelvethook,
who's changed the moniker
to include scooter leg.
That's an homage.
"You mentioned the seven pointed star
"being significant, in Christianity,
"the seven pointed star represents
"the seven gifts of the
spirit, wisdom, understanding,
"council, might, knowledge,
fear, and delight."
Those aren't the gifts of
the spirit that I know.
Yeah, that must be NIV.
It might be the message.
Yeah, it must be.
That's some biblical
translation humor for you.
"So I wondered if this was a metaphor
"for the seven lost causes in some way."
Absolutely, the seven pointed star
is a metaphor for the
lost causes that the cult
needs to get into the spring.
Well, and lemme pair this
with this next question, too,
from Phanto_Moose, who asked
"Can you elaborate on the
Latin used by the cult?
"First one seems to be vita
est aqua, life is water,
"but couldn't completely
figure out the second one,
"electus in-trot aquam sanctum,
selected in holy water?"
Yeah, so all the stuff that
is true about the cult,
like the robes, the seven pointed star,
the Latin chants that are happening,
just to kinda get your
mind in the right place,
all of this was fabricated by Whitewood
as a manipulative scheme
to give the appearances
and trappings of a cult,
or some sort of religious organization
that these people would buy into.
So it isn't--
The Keeper didn't transfer this knowledge
and this symbology to Whitewood,
you know what the Keeper wants,
he wants seven lost causes.
He wants kids of a certain age
with a certain oomph to them,
because there's, his fuel
is associated with that.
But everything else is
Whitewood's problem.
Right, and the seven pointed star,
yes, it was chosen because
the Keeper told him,
"You gotta get seven kids."
And while the seven pointed star
does have significance in Christianity,
it also, like most symbols,
it has significance in other places
including Pagan religion,
and we just took it and
turned it upside down
so that the predominant arrow--
Let's say Whitewood turned it upside down.
Was pointing down towards
the Earth, towards water.
Also, the triangle in general in Paganism
is a symbol of water,
'cause it's pointing down.
It's also a symbol of feminism
because of the triangle.
What's that got to do with this?
I'm just letting you know.
It wasn't a joke, I'm
just letting you know.
Now, the Latin specifically, so again,
my thought process behind this was,
so, when we were writing
the section about the cult,
I was like "Okay, well
what could they chant,"
and I was like "All right, well,
what if there was something
"that was like life is
water or water is life,
"and then once they get down
there and they're selecting
"the specific person to go into,
"put their hand into the water,
"it'll be the selected one,
"or the chosen one enters the water,"
and I can't remember whether
or not the chosen one
refers to the person
chosen in sort of the weird
duck duck goose game, or
if it's Whitewood himself,
but anyway, it was very simply
putting the meaning into Google Translate,
and going from English to
Latin, until we got something
that, "Oh, that kinda seems
like it could be a cool chant."
And also, I was thinking at the time,
"We're probably gonna get
a couple of things wrong,
"maybe the tense is wrong,
"maybe this isn't a perfect translation,
"but let's not pay too
much attention to it
"because we're trying to make it seem like
"this dude who has no
experience in any of this stuff
"is going to the library
and kinda coming up
"with this language that
wouldn't be perfect."
The system would not be this
perfectly cohesive system
that feels like it has some
sort of supernatural force,
but it's more like
somebody creating something
to fool people, and it's gonna
have some inconsistencies in it,
so "I chose this, and
this is what you chant."
So everything has
significance but it's not,
it doesn't have metaphysical significance,
it's just--
He made it up to make
sense and to manipulate,
you know kinda like, you think
I was gonna throw another
religion or cult under
the bus, didn't you?
So yeah, so the Latin, and the symbology,
the star, the freaking star's
on the side of the book.
Look at that, Whitewood
tainted the spine of our novel.
'Cause there's the star,
that means nothing.
That's a deception, man,
we got it right there
on the spine of the book,
'cause it looks cool.
But it means something now.
It means the lost, yeah, it means...
Or else I shouldn't have got it tattooed
on my left butt cheek.
Oh.
So yeah, he made all that stuff up, y'all.
He made it all up, so then we go back
to facts like, why would a guy
go through all this trouble,
and so not to make, I mean yeah,
I think you do feel for him,
but it doesn't justify his actions,
I mean would you wanna do
anything to save your daughter,
to remove your daughter's
pain, to give her a full life,
well, hopefully not
anything, hopefully not this,
but I mean it's not just the one decision,
he's continually communing
with his daughter,
who's frozen in time.
And every time he goes down there
his heart is wrenched one more time,
so it's like, at a certain point,
he's kind of, again, I'm
not trying to justify this,
but psychologically, you can go crazy
trying to care for somebody,
if you've reached a total dead end,
and especially if it's
like "This is the answer,
"if you just do this."
You can find yourself
becoming convinced of,
or justifying your actions.
Yeah, so we wanted it to be
a little bit messy and complicated,
but ultimately, you're still,
I think if you're normal,
you're still gonna conclude
that none of the stuff
that he's doing is actually justified,
it's just he has his own reasons which may
draw a little bit of sympathy from you,
but not to the point that you
think any of it's justified.
Just think, I mean
you've got this poor girl
who doesn't wanna get out of
her dress getting in there,
"Oh my lord," Wayne
said, "It was working,"
the water all around them began to bubble,
Wayne began to laugh,
unconcerned about disturbing
anyone who might be within earshot.
Ruby laughed too, "This is really fun."
She pushed off the
bottom, beginning to swim.
Wayne was careful not
to let go of her hand.
That didn't matter, though, as
soon as she dropped her face
below the surface, Ruby was violently
sucked down into the water.
Her hand slipped from her father's.
"Ruby!" He yelled, "Baby!"
Then he got spit out.
Moving along, this is a question,
a quick one related to the
spring, Joel McCray asks,
"Are the seven souls
taken by the Keeper dead?
"What happened to them,
do they go to an afterlife
"or just not exist?"
So no, the seven souls that are in there
are in the same situation that Rex,
I mean that Leaf and
Alicia were, in this book.
So, in this state of stasis,
which your body is not aging.
There's some things happening
in your mind, of course,
the longer that you're
there, it seems like the less
you can kinda remember and hold onto
the life that you had before.
And interestingly, this,
I don't wanna get into
too much into this, because I don't like
taking so much of the mystery,
any of the mystery out,
but I will say that
the nature of the spring and
the Keeper of the spring,
and even the nature of this, the void
and the people sort of
being suspended in time,
and kinda trapped in this place,
every element of that is at
least somewhat influenced
by Celtic mythology, right,
and that's why in the book,
they break out the giant
book that talks about,
I can't remember the
name of the book, but,
that's when they get some information
about the nature of the spring
and the blood and all this stuff,
and the blood being the key,
that's because, some of the
particular choices that we made
are just things that we came up with,
but the general idea of there being this
sort of being in charge of
a spring that represents
almost a portal to a slightly
different plane of existence,
these are concepts that
come up time and time again
in Celtic mythology,
which in a second we'll,
when we get to the end, we'll talk about
what does this mean about
a potential second book,
and where else could this go,
but I will say that all of that is,
it's not completely fabricated,
we didn't just invent it out of thin air,
we kinda looked and did some research on
the way people thought about that,
in sort of ancient Celtic times,
and used that to influence us.
So no, long story short,
or long answer short,
those people are not dead,
they're still in the void.
You mentioned when we were
talking about Whitewood,
you said he would come
up with the symbology
and the Latin and stuff
like he went to the library
and was doing research, which
reminds me of this question.
Jade_iemrg, "Is the man who told Janine
"in the library basement about the deaths
"at Whitewood school going
to be talked about at all?
"He disappeared, and I have
a feeling his character
"has a story to be told!"
Yeah, we're working on
a spinoff novel series
about library dude, creepy library dude.
Well first of all, you
ever go to the library?
There's always somebody who, you can tell
they spent a lot of time at the library.
So, maybe Whitewood went there.
Janine definitely went there for answers,
and this guy apparently knew
what she was looking for,
and had a little information, but then,
either he was a ghost, or he just ghosted.
I mean he wanted to help, but...
Do you have a straightforward answer,
because I have a roundabout answer.
Who is this guy?
Well, go ahead.
I just think that in this town,
you can't expect everyone to believe
exactly the same thing,
for there not to be anybody
who's more suspicious, so to me,
it rang true that
there's at least somebody
that you encounter in the story that,
you're not taking this
hook, line, and sinker.
Somebody who's a little bit
of a conspiracy theorist.
But every once in a while,
conspiracy theorists are right.
But then not accepted, kinda like,
we say conspiracy theorist with derision,
and I'm sure in the town, any nay-sayer
would be, who knows what they'd be
scratching on the side of his car?
So it's like, "Hey, I'ma
help you out a little bit,
"but I don't wanna be
associated with this."
Is the simple explanation.
Who is he and how much
does he really know?
And I would say, an
even simpler explanation
that doesn't even, it's very much,
all right, she needs to
do some kind of research
and she needs, again, this
is one of those things
that in storytelling it's like okay, well,
Janine needs to learn something
that the audience needs to also know
in order to move this story forward.
Where would you get this
type of information,
well you would get it at a library.
What kind of town is
Bleak Creek, and also,
what kind of story are we trying to tell?
Okay, so I think the library scene
is actually pretty
indicative of exactly the way
we wanted to write this book,
so the first thing that happens is,
okay, something ironically funny.
There's a loud librarian, it's a simple,
simple joke that we got a
good bit of mileage out of.
And then, oh, but this is
also a scary, scary thing,
so she's gonna go down into this basement,
it's gonna get a little
bit weird when she says
that she's asking about
the Whitewood school,
and what better way to
introduce a little bit of,
I mean she obviously passes this guy
who's kinda following her with his eyes
as she goes down and walks
through the main part
of the library to then go to the basement,
and then what if all of a sudden he's just
right behind her, not necessarily
because there is significance to this guy
that will be explored later,
but mostly because it's
just really creepy.
Because it's a more inventive way
to get this information.
You know that she's
being watched, you know that she's being,
there's a lot, there's
increasing attention
on Janine's efforts, and so how far
is this gonna go, is she gonna be harmed?
And so, hopefully you're thinking that
as you're reading this,
I mean she's lying about the recipes
and that's kinda not going too great.
She kinda, I really enjoy her lies,
but I'm hoping that the reader's like
"Okay, I just don't know
if that lie's good enough,
"I think she might be putting
a target on her back."
Or like I said, on her car, at least.
So then what's this guy gonna do?
And the funny thing is,
it's obvious by the way we ended the book,
which somebody pointed out in a question,
that we want the story to continue.
The book ends with, okay, Ruby's out,
and this is not quite reconciled, I mean,
no justice has been done to
what these adults have been doing,
and what's going on in the
spring, and there's still people
that we love and care
about who are stuck there.
Is Alicia gonna get back to normal,
there's a lot of open
questions, and that was
very very intentional, and I think that
one of the interesting
things that we're finding,
is when you ask this
question about this man,
well I just told you, no, there
was no greater significance
to this guy, he represents an opportunity
to make the scene scary
and he's also indicative
of just the nature of the
town, and like Link said,
that there's gonna be people
who are skeptical about this school.
But, the cool thing about
potentially writing a second book,
is if we wanted there to be
significance to that guy,
and we wanted to make
it almost retroactive,
as long as you don't do
anything that is contradictory
to the way that you set
it up in the first book,
you have the right to do that.
And it's not that we didn't,
I do think it was important
with that guy that,
it does also send the message that
there are potential allies in this town.
Everybody's not against these kids.
It's not just, and Janine, you know?
So, there's a little bit, I'm
just saying there's a little--
But I'm just saying that's not the process
that went into it, it's not the process
that went into it, but we talked about,
we haven't talked about
it at all in the show--
But there's an openness to it,
that's the point I'm making.
You know what, and this
leads to another question,
the question about Dennis,
yes, read that question.
Julia, which is Jula483 asks,
"Was Dennis calling Janine,
"who was still in Bleak Creek
just a weird coincidence,
"or was there something
supernatural happening there?
"Him calling her all of a
sudden when she was in doubt
"and not sure if she should stay or leave
"was almost too perfect."
And a related question from gryffiest,
and she actually replied,
he or she actually replied
to this question, "That,
or I was even thinking
"at the time that he
might've been paid off
"or encouraged by some or
one of the cult members
"to get her to leave town."
I wish I had a really
awesome answer to this.
But the answer is, no, it was just
the best way to tell the story.
It was dramatic timing.
It was a little too perfect, well yeah,
yeah, it might've been
a little too perfect,
but sometimes you need your
characters to do something
that will do the perfect
thing for your story.
Hey, things happen
serendipitously in real life, too.
Yeah, they do all the time.
But, which--
You wanna avoid the cumulative effect
of a lot of that happening
and driving the story forward.
We didn't make it, there's not a whole lot
of super convenient things that happen,
but there are some
convenient things that happen
so you don't have to sit
through an unnecessary chapter
to move the story forward.
And also, it's our first novel, I'm sure--
Listen, don't apologize.
Well, but I'll also say that I read
well-established writers all the time,
and I see things that I'm like
"Whoa, that right there is
so convenient that it's,"
and I tend to not be very judgmental
about that kind of thing,
but I find some things get
too convenient sometimes.
I don't think this is
necessarily one of 'em,
but I think it relates
to the question that we
were answering before which was,
kinda the way the
intentions and symbolism,
in fact I was in a classroom last week,
while I was doing this tour of this place,
and in the writing classroom,
the English classroom, there was a,
I'm gonna get this
wrong, but the quote was,
"I don't know whether the author intended
"what my teacher says they intended
"or if she's just making it up."
But it was a very funny way
to kind of word that, and I think that...
We're just glad to be a
part of the discussion.
I think it may have been Hank Green
talking about his book, but
somebody had seen something
in his book and he was like
"Oh, I'd like to take credit for that,
"but no, and I'm glad that
you see that that way."
But I think it goes
back to the process of,
once you put yourself in
a certain frame of mind,
and you're in a certain
setting, and you're telling
a certain story, there
are going to be things
that, even the observation that you made
about the nature of the
friendship and the way
that they held hands around the tree,
the observation that you
made in the documentary,
which wasn't, the reason
we put it in the book
is because, well that
was what we remembered.
We remembered three people holding hands
around a tree and not being able to reach,
and then you made the
connection that this is like,
well, if two people are holding hands,
the other two people
can't be holding hands,
and so it sorta represents
the inherent tension
in a three-way relationship.
It's not that that's not true,
it's just that that wasn't intended.
People can find the meaning in that,
and I think that's totally fine,
to find the meaning in something,
but that doesn't mean that
all of that was there,
it's just you're in a
certain frame of mind
when you're writing, and then the person's
in a certain frame of
mind when they're reading,
there's gonna be connections made,
and for me that's just a beautiful part of
the reading process, is
that finding those things,
and attaching meaning, even in places
that it could've been
subconsciously inserted by a writer.
Doesn't necessarily
have to be intentional.
I think that was the case there,
because we were very much talking about
the relational dynamics and,
Leaf trying to confess his crush,
and that being thwarted, it's like,
and then that's the very next
thing that we talk about.
And you know, it's an easy connection.
Let's move to the--
Well, keeping in the same theme,
this question from Nicole
Tennant, sundayrain26,
"Is there any significance
to the blue frog?"
So Ruby's blue frog left on the bed.
And yes, there is very
specific significance to it,
I don't know exactly where it could go,
but the reason that it's a blue frog
is of course the blue sorta represents
the theme of water that
we're dealing with,
and that's why the robes
are blue in the cult,
but the frog is, of course, amphibious,
which represents the ability
to go between two different worlds,
two different modes of existence.
A frog being able to go
underwater and then on land.
And who does that?
And also, the frog itself does have,
once you start kinda searching, spiritual
or symbology of frog
or something like that,
you'll be taken to 12 different websites,
and they all kinda have a
different interpretation,
but I did find one
website that talked about,
there's sort of a spiritual analog
to the amphibious nature of a frog,
being that it represents
the ability to kind of
go between two planes of existence,
both the physical world
and the spiritual world.
And I think that the void does represent
some sort of metaphysical
spiritual plane of existence
that isn't necessarily the
other world or underworld,
but it's something different, and so,
that is the significance of the frog.
Where we're gonna go with
that, we don't know exactly,
but yes, there's a reason
that it was a frog,
and that wasn't accidental.
And if you remove the r
in frog, you get what?
Fog, and fog is something
that lingers over what?
A bog.
Water.
Okay, Austin Reed,
Reapercrew96, "Can we talk about
"the very last scene when
Alicia's going down the street
"and sees Ruby in the epilogue?
"Is that a hint at a second book?
"When Ruby got out of the
spring is she still a little kid
"or has she grown up the 10 years?
"#earbiscuits."
She has not grown up the 10 years,
she's the same age she
was when she went in.
She's seven years old.
So yeah, let's talk about that scene.
Is it a hint at a second
book, wouldn't I like to know.
I hope so.
Yeah, it was our...
A second book that doesn't
exist yet, but yeah.
It was our big hint at the fact
that we want to write a second book.
It's not necessarily up to us,
whether or not there
will be a second book,
but it represented our
intention that there will be.
But it would be cool to
have Ruby in a second book.
Oh yeah.
Or maybe we just forget about her,
say "You know what, that's
just a dangling participle,
"let's move on to something else.
"Forget about Ruby, she's not
gonna be in the second book."
Was there another question?
I think, I thought there was
another Ruby question, but--
Yeah, there is.
From Lex, "Why was Ruby the
most attached to the Keeper
"when she wasn't the first
kid to drown in the spring?"
'Cause you know, there's
Timothy, who was in there,
who's the kid who, I can't
remember how many years ago
it would've been, but basically
when the spring shut down,
was when he "drowned"
according to his parents,
according to the people in the town,
the Bleak family that
was running the resort,
he drowned, but we know he
didn't drown, he's been in there.
Okay, so why is it that the
Keeper is sorta speaking through
and obviously more attached to Ruby?
Again--
Well his question was why
is Ruby so attached to the,
I guess it's the same question both ways.
Well, again, I think the answer
is the most straightforward and that is,
the Keeper wants more children, right,
the Keeper's made that very clear.
Apparently, he didn't have any,
Timothy being down there
wasn't doing anything for him,
but Ruby, because of the
way it ended up working out
where both Ruby and Whitewood
went down at the same time,
now the Keeper's an opportunist, right,
so the Keeper knows that "Now
I've got the carrot, Ruby,
"in the spring, and now I
can manipulate Whitewood,
"and get him to do my bidding."
And so he's naturally going
to be more attached to Ruby
because she is the way that he
can accomplish his purposes.
Unlike Timothy, which, apparently
hasn't worked out so well.
Right, so I mean,
let's shift to more of a summary of,
okay, so where does this leave us?
I mean, rest assured, we've
given a lot of thought
to where we're leaving the reader, and,
yeah, we've given a lot of thought
to where we wanna take you in a followup,
which, we're not saying
that's definitely happening,
'cause we don't know that
that's definitely happening
at this point, but we certainly hope
that we'll have the opportunity
to write a second book,
so honestly, the more
buzz that can be generated
around this book, the greater
the chances that we get
the opportunity to write this second book,
which we've already been working on, so.
Yeah, we know where we want
to go in the second book,
again, it's just a question of,
will we have the privilege to do so?
Okay, so in summary, where
we leave off in book one.
And this is, if you for some reason
have decided to listen to this podcast
up until this point...
And now you're thinking you wanna read it?
You really need to pause the podcast,
because I'm gonna summarize where it ends,
so just don't listen to this, please.
There are a number of people
who are inside the void,
Ben, 'cause he was taken
by the wave at the end,
Josefina, the girl who befriended
Alicia inside Whitewood.
Josefina really liked that
frog, I will say that.
You know, I was like "Josefina,"
and this is me just
putting myself in the mind
of the reader, "Why you
keep touching that frog,
"and messing up Ruby's room so much?"
That made me uncomfortable.
The fact that they were getting
too comfortable in that room,
and then Whitewood snatched 'em up.
The two kids who were thrown
in during the commotion
at the end of the book, so
there was the crazy moments,
where they're getting Leaf and Alicia out,
but there are other kids
being thrown in and rejected,
well Patrick Small and
April Lee are two kids
that are mentioned as missing
at the end of the book
by the sheriff, but they are in the void.
There are three former Whitewood students
who've been there for years,
since their supposed deaths,
that's Richard Stanley in 1982,
a 16 year old girl, unnamed.
She's the one that, Richard Stanley
was the one in the oven,
and the 16 year old girl
was the one that was smoking
next to the gas leak, supposedly.
That was stupid.
And then there was the boy
that was struck by lightning
in 1989 who's also unnamed.
That really happened.
And then there's Timothy Bleak,
who's the first kid to ever
be taken into the spring,
at least in the span of our story.
Maybe things happened
before, I don't know.
He's been there since 1961,
when he "drowned" in quotes.
And that shut down the
original Bleak Creek resort.
Now you might do the
math on that and realize
that that's more than seven
kids, that's eight kids,
and again, or is that, no, if
you count Ruby that's nine.
If you count Ruby that's nine.
The seven kids was just a number,
the seven additional kids
given to Whitewood for,
again, I don't try to
put too much logic behind
why the Keeper needs a certain number.
But if he's saying seven,
that must mean his real number was nine.
Yeah, and you could get
into some numerology there,
if you want, and the significance of seven
and the significance of nine,
if you wanna read about that a little bit,
I'm not gonna say that
that isn't at least,
it works out nicely.
Go to the library.
See who comes up to you.
Oh, the library guy, don't forget him.
Now, the sheriff, Sheriff
Lawson and the rest of the cult,
Mary Hattoway, Shackleford, et cetera.
Now Mary Hattoway's dead.
You wish, ahahaha!
She ain't dead.
About to say.
She's so likable.
They have explained everything to the town
by saying that Whitewood
was acting nefariously,
kidnapping, murdering kids.
They basically say that the original kids
from the 80s are presumed dead,
but the most recent
four, which would be Ben,
Josefina, Patrick and April,
are just presumed missing.
With Whitewood on the lam.
Maybe being held someplace
with Whitewood, again,
I'm just giving you,
this is all the stuff
that the sheriff says
at the end, just so your
mind'll be in the right place.
And the cult itself still believes that
the seven lost causes are being purified
by the one below, and
that they will return
as the seven shepherds.
Poor Travis.
They just don't know how
long it's gonna take.
I mean you're mad at Travis because he,
he double-crossed 'em, but it's just,
just to use the parlance of the situation,
it's testimony to Whitewood's ability
to manipulate that Travis,
a guy who's so genuine,
such a good-hearted guy,
endeavor to deceive,
to keep that from the
kids as much as he did.
Which then, is there a
rereading of the scene
at the river, what does
that tell you about Travis?
If you take another look at
that scene, with the button.
It's not for us to answer, I'm just saying
it's just food for
thought for the rereader.
Travis is one of my favorite
characters, by the way.
Rex, Leaf, Alicia, and Hornhat,
and all the other kids
who were in the school
are compelled, effectively
compelled to remain quiet
for the fear that the sheriff or the cult
will kill their parents,
do other crazy stuff.
And then anybody who decides
that they're gonna say
something could also be
dismissed pretty easily,
'cause you got a bunch of
traumatized kids that have
been in this weird place
that, of course they're
gonna say things about it.
And then finally, Janine and Donna,
they've shown their film,
which has been interpreted
by the initial audience as--
A precursor to Blair Witch,
in a very loose sense, I guess.
Yeah, basically a mockumentary,
a fictional documentary.
Not a true expose.
Somebody did ask the question,
"Why did you make the
decision to do that,"
and well, it's because we
don't want the loop to,
if all of a sudden it was like
"And she makes a film
and everybody sees that
"they're all crazy,
murderous cult members,"
well then the case is closed on that,
we don't want the case to be closed.
Yeah, I mean the cult successfully
destroyed the most damning information,
and so you're left kinda like,
I think it's a pretty
reasonable response, I think,
it's like "Ah, okay, this
is a marketing ploy."
Yeah.
All right, so, where does that leave us?
Well, #EarBiscuits, first of all,
if you wanna continue this discussion,
and if you wanna join the Mythical Society
or if you're already a member,
make sure you talk about it
on Discord, there's chapter by chapter
Discord conversations happening.
And listen, we, like Link said,
yes, we wanna continue telling this story.
The only way that's gonna
happen is if the book
continues to be a success,
and that requires the book to continue
to break outside of this, the
community of mythical beasts.
Of course, you guys have
been super supportive,
and many of you have bought it,
but we need to demonstrate
continued interest
in the fact that this thing is bigger
than just the mythical beasts.
So that means buying
the book for somebody,
encouraging them to read it,
maybe they don't, maybe
you tried to introduce them
to the world of mythicality
before but you sent them
a video where we were
eating animal testicles,
and that's not their thing,
we do other things, as we've
hopefully demonstrated with this book,
that I think are maybe
even more accessible.
So, share the book.
And did you say leave an Amazon review?
I didn't say that, but you
should do that as well.
That's a big help, if
you've read the book--
Or Goodreads as well.
So on Goodreads or Amazon,
please leave a review
of "The Lost Causes of Bleak Creek,"
it makes a difference and
we truly appreciate it.
I'ma give a quick rec,
I was telling you about
this right beforehand, so,
shifting gears a little bit.
I've never listened to Jim James,
lead singer of My Morning Jacket,
but I stumbled upon a
song on his new album,
solo album called The Order of Nature.
The song that I listened
to first was called
"Set it to Song,"
but this is the Louisville Orchestra
and Teddy Abrams teamed up with Jim James
to make this song cycle,
it's unbelievable how
this thing works, but,
lemme, I'll just read the summary of this,
he has so many albums in
there, all so distinct,
and I've just been introduced
to the world of Jim James,
so I've just scratched the surface,
you can come along with me.
"A fully orchestrated song
cycle titled The Order of Nature
"in which James pondered the
roles of hatred and compassion
"in the natural world."
Is his latest album, recorded live with
the Louisville Orchestra.
That's pretty amazing.
He's on tour, too, I
gotta try to see that.
Well, he's gonna be in Denver on May 15th.
Let's go to Denver.
Jim James.
All right, #EarBiscuits, let's
keep the conversation going,
thanks for hanging out with us
and for enjoying the spoilers.
And we'll be here for another,
how many episodes do we have left,
two additional episodes in 2019,
and then we're going to
take another two week break.
Be back on January sixth.
'Cause your boys gotta have a break.
And yeah, we'll be back
bigger and better than ever,
actually, it'll be exactly the same.
Or will it?
I don't think it will be, actually.
To watch more Ear Biscuits,
click on the playlist on the right.
To watch the previous
episode of Ear Biscuits,
click on the playlist to the left.
And don't forget to click
on the circular icon to subscribe.
If you prefer to listen to this podcast,
it's available on all your
favorite podcast platforms.
Thanks for being your mythical best.